what advice do you give about going into
but look at me this is
but the first
the first wife's not happy
like the elimination is not conditional
for the first to have to be happy or not
of course better off to speak to the
first wife
but you know
the the whole I mentioned you can have
second wife third wife
what was happening now a light is very
sad sisters some sisters not all of them
they don't mind the husband to go
comments as long as I have second wife
or a third wife or a fourth wife
there's a brother I know personally told
me his wife said I don't mind you going
to Haram I don't have second wife
I said you should divorce women
is not a good woman to have
so there's no condition for the first
wife to be happy
or to be pleased
none we can advise that
and this this goes back to
why there's a lot of problems
because we turn away from Dr Sunnah
where do we get this hate in polygeny is
it from Prophet Muhammad he's from
sahaba is it from the the is from the
Muslims it's from the European they
approach it to us
their brainwashed us
okay to have girlfriends but it's hard
to have another wife
alhamdulillah
the brother from America she said the
Sheikh wrote a book is forgot the name
there's a new book came out about
the Imports of polygeny
religion is good for society
doesn't mean someone in the position
didn't work for him or for her therefore
I forgot the name of the the Brotherhood
the book
foreign
yeah two wives and Allah provides for
him
now some sisters only for any excuse for
the brother to not have another wife no
you have to take me a hash you have to
take me to Spain you have to take me to
China take me to Morocco take me to
Albania
take me to
actually
this is uh now there is some people are
misusing
but doesn't mean they also stop it
oh we have two wives there's a problems
even when you have one wife there's
problems so when you stop getting
married
it's from Islam
so they did
and when a woman accepts Allah
blessed marriage
and they say no it's only for that for
the man there's no it's only for the man
not for both
could you get a lecture
for our sisters on how to obey our
husbands
we also get a lecture for
the brothers how to be good husbands
did something
like this in uh Marcus Sunda but no
doubt it's very needed it's needed
to have a good uh Malik
the book is the wisdom of Beauty in a
plural marriage
in the western world
you know Allah Akbar Allah Akbar Allah
Akbar
Allah
said whoever
tried to go against Allah accept Allah
expose him
they try to make try to make it seem
having more than one wife is oppression
is wrong
Allah now happened fornication will
become widespread in their societies
many children that don't even know their
mothers let alone their fathers
many children in the Western World they
don't even know their own mothers let
alone their own fathers
subhanallah
how many of them pretend like you know
having more than wife is oppression then
they found out he go to prostrate houses
and is married
when you try to go against Allah Allah
no doubt is needed for the husband to
have a lecture
foreign
before
sometimes when divorce happened between
I mean when the force happens
the brother who make his ex -wife as if
shaytan
and the wife she will make him seem as
it was
they forgot everything what they had in
the past
the good time
and they go online
or some sisters please tell us that us
tell us about what happened
she goes her way
that's Islamic teaching
and my advice for sisters don't get
involved
don't get involved in people's marriage
except you want to give good advice
but don't get involved there are people
you know subhanallah you know yourself
speaking to a brother it's very
important to listen to both sides
foreign
the privacy
of a husband or the husband goes and
expose the privacy of his wife
or his ex-wife
may Allah protect us
recently a brother came to me
he said his wife accused him of
uh
uh sexual abuse
the abuse that sexually
and the guy the brother the man was
crying man
it takes a lot for men to cry
it's Allah and it's not the first time
happen
Allah is watching you if you want to
take the government as your protector on
their judgments ask them to protect in
front of Allah
it doesn't mean that doesn't happen
sometimes it happened this matter should
be taken serious
but even though they they don't take it
serious the way they used to before
because why they've not sometimes a
woman just lie
how many stories you hear who discovered
the woman uh accused husband of evil
things that they found out that the son
is even his son
I will be living there protect the
Muslims for this evil thing
or green
or feminism we need to go back to Quran
Sunnah
and of course we human beings we get
angry
sometimes you have to do your own way
I remember Allah is watching us
Allah is watching us
and there's a sister mashallah she was
a blessed sister her husband was going
around
and speaking about her about personal
issues she didn't even say one word and
guess him said look at him Allah forgive
him I don't want to speak divorce
I'm going to cut him with my own life
but
subhanallah
and this uh ex-husband who's called
everyone cursing her speaking about her
to strangers
I said drama sister alhamdulillah
divorced you
alhamdulillah divorce you
can you put in your con can you put the
condition
in your condition for your husband not
to have another wife
yeah I mean some Scholars out of
Amana said yeah you can't do it
said no you cannot do it because this
Allah
because he's right which Allah gave him
unless
condition and
subscribe you can and if you accept it
he has to fulfill it and some Squad said
no it doesn't have to fulfill because
why this condition goes and gets and
gets Sunnah
so you see if you go condition he's
gonna say I don't follow the opinion for
the other opinion now
and why anyway I don't know which
selfies do that I mean like which woman
needs to poor condition
on her husband before we get married you
have to have another wife
no this is like
anyway
I never heard according to my knowledge
little knowledge that the self used to
do that we follow sorry
look
I mean like this is a western mentality
man
condition this that
if a man was to take a second wife
is it not uh
is it not the hustle
for him to
have the financial ability
to do so yeah no doubt
yeah
so go have another wife
so what that means able to provide for
them yes I
um he said I'm very surprised how come
people do not seek provision through
marriage Allah provide
open doors
but yes it has to be Justin
that's out there
is a financial ability to do so that's
how the
I can't read the last part
but you're right yeah financially has to
be
uh what they call it
uh
able
to provide for both of them except if
they both agree
on certain conditions that is no problem
for example if the wife said listen you
don't have to uh which which they call
it like
you don't have to provide for me or I'll
have to give me a house I have a house
so but if she uh
he has to provide for a house then he
has to do it
he has to do it I also provide for a
house in the
uh provide for as well generally
speaking
again many questions about secret wife
first inshallah If You Don't lecture
about it
protect us all and may Allah
make us from those inwardly
in this life and then day after
and then protects us from there
the evil of this life and the hereafter
my advice to my sisters likewise for the
brothers who are watching
be aware of what they call it
be aware
of speaking about your personal issues
online
he divorced his wife
then
she took something from him he took us
to the courts
and she was wearing a cup
and the the cardi the the judge is set
to
to the woman to show her face
so the ex-husband said no I don't want
to show her face he said yeah but you
know it's hard that you are referring to
he said no it's okay I forgive her
so he had the jealousy for his wife even
they got divorced now what we see from
the brothers and the sisters is
unacceptable
online
who encourages Behavior
to for the woman to go speak about her
ex-husband
like this just
oh likewise for both the husband and the
wife
sometimes of course shaytan will come to
us
say for the brothers you have to try
your real man
you know you're sure you don't care
when you come to all of us including
myself I'm very Adam
I just remember that Allah is watching
us
and remember if we're gonna deal with
our marriage issues of course our
desires
then
it's not going to be fruitful
let us try to control our anger and our
emotion and remember Allah has watched
us
and remember the best solution is to
go on about it according to the Quran
Sunnah
and advice to my sisters
said don't challenge your man don't
judge your husband
don't challenge your husband
husband doesn't like woman that act like
a man behave like a man
Allah creates a woman
with softness and gentleness
that's what attracts a man to woman
when she's soft and gentle
sometimes country said look you have to
show him your own cat
no mabala is watching you too
loud